hi guys now some of you asked me to give
you some tips on how to grow
taller well i made a video about it
around three years ago when i was still
a new youtuber
and a lot of things changed since then
so it's time to redo that video
and give you the best tips i got
now just very quick if it's the first
time that you're here on my channel i'm
daniel and welcome to dln
men's lifestyle so if you haven't
subscribed yet please consider it also
click that notification bell
so you won't miss any of the next videos
now
if you want to grow as tall as you can
the first thing
you need to know is what determines your
height
and second what are the things that you
do bad habits
that actually cause you or stop you from
achieving
your full height potential well research
shows us that there are
basically two things that determines
your height
what are they genetics which you got
from your family
and environmental factors these are
things like your diet
now you need to know that you can't do
anything about your genetics
and it determines 60 to 80 percent of
your height
but and this is important you can do
something
about the environmental factors and that
determines
20 to 40 percent of your height and
that's a lot
20 to 40 percent of your height a lot of
guys out there in the world
are actually shorter than they would
have been because i didn't know about
the environmental factors
that influenced their growth so let me
give you a few tips on how to increase
your height
[Music]
number one have a balanced diet this is
super
important think about it if you don't
give your body
what it needs to grow you're not going
to reach your full
high potential so eat a lot of protein
like eggs
poultry fish and good dairy products
that will help your bones and muscles to
grow
and green veggies like spinach and kale
also helps you to get more calcium
and then get enough vitamin d why
because vitamin d helps bone and muscle
growth
if you don't get enough vitamin d it can
stunt your growth which is definitely
not what you want
so how do you get more vitamin d well
you find it in foods like fish
mushrooms red meat egg yolks liver and
some dairy products
like milk but the best way to get
vitamin d is just to get it
from the sun so just go more outside if
you struggle if you struggle with time
if you got to work a lot indoors
then you can also try supplements i'll
add it for you in the video description
down below so you can check it out
number two get enough sleep
sleep is so important so it's time to
stop playing all day computer games or
playstation games right through the
night it's time to get
some sleep did you know that you
actually grow more
when you sleep so if you're under 20 and
still grow you can try to get 9 to 11
hours of sleep
if you do sleep will produce more hgh
which is basically your growth
hormone number three
just exercise more yeah it's true if you
exercise a lot more in your teenage
years
it can increase your height and the
easiest way to do
it is just to join a gym or just join a
sport team at school that you like
number four stop using things that stunt
your growth
there are a lot of teenagers that use
certain things that
stops them from achieving their full
height potential
what kind of things well things like
drugs and alcohol they can stunt your
growth
some people believe drinking coffee can
also stunt your growth
but that's not true there's no evidence
to back it up so if you want to have
coffee
enjoy it i love it too another thing
that can stunt your growth
is steroids this is something well
just stay away from it this is better
another thing
is smoking some teens get group pressure
and start smoking because they think
it's cool it's not if you smoke or
if you're exposed to second-hand smoking
it's scientifically proven that it can
stunt your growth and i've said this in
a previous video and i'll say it now
again
if there are any parents listening to
this video stop
smoking in front of your kids it's just
plain
bad parenting no is it possible to grow
taller after 18
well for most people listen very
carefully for most people
it's not going to happen most people
stop growing between the ages of 18 and
21
some even 22. why do they stop growing
what is because of your growth plates in
your bones
basically your growth plates start to
close at the end of puberty
that's just how we were created it's
basically your hormonal changes that
stops or hardens your growth plates
now is there anything that you can do if
you're unhappy with your height
after 20 years well there's a few
products that you can try
like growth boom pro or growth synorama
wmx but to be honest here i just don't
think it will work
i did some research i looked into it
three years ago i did it again
i just don't trust it for me there's no
evidence that it will work
now some people also try gh treatments
growth hormone treatments and it does
work with children but it doesn't really
work with
adults you can check it out and do your
own research
then there's also surgery also known as
limb
lengthening surgery where they do
several surgeries to lengthen your legs
and tendons in the legs now i'm not a
fan of this either because
well it costs money and there's a couple
of side effects as well
there are risks here are some of the
risks with the surgery there are risks
with bleeding
infections and anesthesia and there's a
risk that the surgery won't work
if your bones don't heal properly other
risks include
non-union leg length discrepancy nerve
stretch
injury tendon contracture leading to
stiff joints
and joint arthritis and you need to know
that it can take
up to one or two years for you to
recover
i'm just not a fan of it at all but you
can take some time
to your own research into it if you want
to try it out now
apart from these things there are three
things that you can do to make yourself
appear look more taller
number one is improve your posture
all you gotta do to just look taller is
to improve your posture because if you
don't
you look shorter than you actually are
so all you got to do is stand up
straight
pull your head up look straight forward
your shoulders
back and if you've got a belly pull it
in
now some people believe that you can
grow taller by just doing stretching
exercises
but does it actually work well no
if you stretch and strengthen your back
core and your whole body
it helps you to maintain good posture
and then you automatically
look taller if you stretch and do
hanging exercises
it can reverse the compression of your
spine
making you slightly taller but only
until it compresses again
so you don't really grow taller at all
all that happens is your back
over time kinda compresses and then you
do hanging stretching exercise and then
straight snaps again right
but then after a while it goes back to
its original
position you don't grow taller
[Music]
number two you can wear shoes with
inserts in them and also with higher
soles
that will add a few centimeters and you
will look taller
[Music]
number three gain more muscle this helps
a lot of people to feel better about
themselves
if you're short and skinny a lot of
people don't like it
right they don't feel good enough about
themselves so if you go and you work out
then you automatically feel a little bit
better about yourself because then
you're a little bit bigger and stronger
so then you might gain more confidence
in the way that you look
[Applause]
number four style your hair up
it sounds silly but you'll actually look
a few centimeters taller than you
actually are
now let me give you some honest advice
try to find a way to accept the way that
you are try to accept
your height that's a lot better compared
to
trying all these extreme measures just
to increase your height
instead of being obsessed with your
height start to focus
on your other strengths build that out
more
focus on it become more who you really
are
god made you the way you are for a
reason you
are unique you are made in his image
listen there's a lot of things in this
world
that you won't be able to control you
can't do anything about it
but you can change the way you think
about it
and how you react to it let me give you
something that will help
as a tall person it's not fun
it's not great being tall all the time
it's not fun hitting your head
against things maybe for other people
because you're tall but it's not fun not
to have space
for your legs in a car or in a plane or
your feet getting cold
when it hangs over the bed and it's not
fun always needing to bend down to see
yourself in a mirror
i can go on the whole day but the end
you gotta make peace
with your own body accept who you are
because that is who
you are you are unique there's no one
out there like you
in the whole world short or tall
we are all different we're all unique
and there's a reason for it
own it don't be shy because you're a
little bit shorter than other people
don't be shy
because you're a little bit taller than
other people it's who
you are now remember life is short
so don't waste yours i'll see you guys
in the next video cheers